hello my name is Spike Lee and besides
making film you may not know him a
10-year film professor I teach them and
I love movies so gonna be talking about
some of some films that I love director
Elia Kazan and the writer but she'll
burn first I want to talk about is a
pairing of a writer and director two
films they did back-to-back the director
illa Kazan and the writer my good good
friend is longer with us but she'll berg
and the two film that had back-to-back
on the waterfront and a face in the
crowd on the waterfront great script
great acting directing cinematography I
mean the whole boxing thing came came
from but I mean a lot of the actors in
the film were ex boxers that that that
bud talk to saying you know and you
should you should look at he guys and
put them in but choose love was boxing
he's in the Boxing Hall of Fame as a
writer I was very fortunate to meet but
Schulberg me but we're tight and bud
took an interest in me and we talked
about writing and in fact we wrote a
script together called saves Joe Lewis
about the friendship between a Mac
smelling and Joe Lewis as epic film and
he was at those two Joe Lewis smelling
fights the first one Schmeling knocked
out Joe Lewis but the second fight he
was widely thought that whoever won this
fight would determine to win a world war
ii and stars
FDR Hitler Eleanor Roosevelt
gurbles Sugar Ray Robinson I mean they
liked
epic and during buds last year those who
call me once a week saying spike did you
get the money yet spike to get the money
yet yeah I made a promise to bug that uh
one day soon then we get the money and
I'm gonna keep that problems and get
that that film eight is a great script
it was wonderful working for bud I've
always been amazed by how Kazan and bud
worked together it was a great
partnership and they made to my favorite
films I never got to meet Marlon Brando
but at the do the right thing came out
he'd called me must been like 2:00 in
the morning and he said he had seen do
the right thing and he wanted me to do a
film about Native Americans I never
heard from after that but it was Justin
had a note he sent me a note to and I
got to find that I remember he signed it
but Justin Marlon but I wanted him this
the only brand on that note too but
amazing film the film they made directly
after that it's called face in the crowd
and bud had the crystal ball in this
film he predicted the power television
even viagra and the film they called
vitajex
but it's really about the power of the
media at that time television and how it
can be harmful how it could be dangerous
how it could make people believe
anything and that don't applies
specifically today to the people who
were in the White House
so those are my I mean I think that's an
you know that was up so my programming
the one of these uh retro theaters I'd
be a great double bill Kazan shield
birds
you look as Ann's direction but she'll
Brooks
riding on the waterfront and a face in a
crown
that's that's the double bill martin
scorsees my late mother
Jacqueline Shelton Lee she loved films
my father hated films a great jazz
bassist composer my father Billy did the
score for she's gonna have it school
days do the right thing and mo better
blues anyway my father hated films they
love sports so true my biggest loves
sitting with music and sports came from
my parents anyway my mother would take
me to movies I was the eldest my mother
would take me to movies because my
father I was my movie I was my mother's
a movie date my father wouldn't go to
movies hated films particularly for how
they portrayed you know black people at
that time my mother responsible for me
being a great fan of Martin Scorsese she
took me to see mean streets whatever
year that was asked that's the year when
he went at that time I didn't want to be
a film and I know people I didn't know
people make films you just you just went
to the movie theater but that still
really made it had an impact on me and I
remember the first time I met Marty I
was in weiu
he had a screen of after hours and
afterwards I went up to him I told the
story he still remembers it so I knew I
made a impact on him just by just
talking to him telling us I liked the
film and we've been friends ever since
tell us my first time I saw Robert De
Niro the Harvey and what was familiar
about the film is that we my family we
the first black family in Cobble Hill
was his neighborhood
in Brooklyn and back then it was stone
tying American I mean like that was it
because of the docs cowboy Hills right
next to Doc's and the docs was you know
at that time at in Brooklyn you know
it's all tiny American so I was very
kind of familiar with those those of
those guys that are in that film uh mean
streets so it was very gratifying to me
to been a young kid growing up a scene
he's no one's getting to meet the people
later on and not just films I mean
growing up my heroes were Willie Mays
Joe Namath Muhammad Ali and I got to
meet these people became friendly with
these people so I got to work with Marty
tell another story uh we we have kind of
a similar gruesome taste and he called
me up one day spike I want to see you
something I want to show you something
and it was good fellows and there's a
scene where they get to the head the
guy's head and device he was showing me
something news that the cut out we cut
in the city its eyes pop out a holiday
is it it is funny be Mario dying
laughing aback they're not gonna let you
do this I know I know that's what you
see at the girl
I mean we're that type of uh you might
say dark humor but I said how'd you do
that it's a special thanks bike special
flex the bet the guys it was the place
they go I remember that yes show me more
say that's all that's all you see spike
that's it that's it yeah
god I've been blessed but to thank my
mother for my love of cinema
Charles blonde in film school in white
graduate films cholesterin really began
to to look at films and one film had a
great impact was Charles blonds night of
the hunter and this only film that he
directed black and white very very scary
film I love it and Robert Mitchum that
character played is terrifying
he is tattooed on his fingers love and
hate and it made such an impact on me
and later on I connected kiss start
wearing these finger rings I said wait a
minute we should have a little bit hate
on the thing and so that that's become
an iconic but that came from his tattoos
but also in the script that whole speech
about love and hate is written by James
Agee you know we had radar him say that
you know we had a couple of changes but
that film I love that film and so a lot
of these films that you know I'm talking
about you know I show to my students
because sometimes never heard these
films but uh they need to see him and I
try to emphasize to them that you know
Grayson was made before your you were
born we epic films of David Lee
when her his dick is not migrate my my
great-great cymet Oliver and classmate
we were my you together
Ernest was the best team at Agra for the
graduate films we shot all my student
films also shot for me she's gonna have
it school days the right thing
mo better and the final thing worked on
Malcolm X and Ernst I wanted to make
Malcolm X in the spirit of the great
epic films of David Lean Daksha bago
Bridger required and especially lawns
Arabia and it just so happened
Columbia Pictures have put out a
restored version of the film and Ernst
and I went to seed at the Ziegfeld
it's I don't just want to say that it's
criminal someone should go to jail that
the Ziegfeld is now ballroom I love
Mexico I was very fortunate you know
many as later they have I was able to
have my premieres at the Ziegfeld
anyway Ernest and I went to see the
restoration of David Lean's Lawrence of
Arabia at the Ziegfeld and it was it was
just amazed as a new print it redid the
sound color and then definitely
influenced us Ernst now you know we want
we wanted Malcolm X they had the epic
feel of it David Lean film was a big
subject so you know need to be epic you
know that's why not a [ __ ] ed pick film
is two hours that ain't epic you got yo
it three hours you know can you tell a
big story it takes time
Malcolm X was a little over three hours
what I like to say that there's not a
law that you have to go to the film
school and be a filmmaker film schools
cost a lot of money and many people make
the smart choice that I can buy a camera
and lights and a bunch of stuff without
paint tuition I just tell my students
that there's no such thing as overnight
success that you gotta bust your ass and
don't take any shortcuts
you're doing it to be rich and famous
that's not gonna be enough for when the
hardship comes gonna be doing it because
that's what you love is your calling and
miss what you want to do for the rest of
your life that won't get you in a rough
tough